becoming the next Bill Nye was a month
on class that we taught at MIT it was a
class to teach students how to use video
to engage an audience and the things
they're excited about in science
technology engineering and math it was
workshop based very intensive we held it
every day and we had everyone from
undergrads freshman to grad students
coming in from all sorts of different
disciplines and they basically had a
chance to learn how to script pre
produce and host a five-minute YouTube
video and we had everything from videos
on how braces work to how time travel
works to fractals and then we took some
of our favorite projects and turn them
into the third season of mi t--'s
original web series science at lab we
had a teaching team that was about as
big as our class itself
we had educators producers hosts I think
the most valuable members of our
teaching team were a group of middle
schoolers that we had come in one day as
our class consultants and our students
actually had to pitch their video ideas
to them because who better to know the
YouTube landscape better than a bunch of
preteens so on the MIT OpenCourseWare
site you'll pretty much get as close of
an experience to actually taking the
classes these students did because
you'll find the syllabus and you'll find
all the assignments but then on top of
that you'll find video lectures where we
really tried to capture every single
candid moment that happened in the class
and then in particular if you're an
educator there is a special section
called this course at MIT where you'll
get very specific instructor insights as
to how we approach designing this class
how we ran it you'll get our
confessionals and sort of insights into
our pedagogical approaches and teaching
a class like this the great thing is all
these materials all of our experiences
and resources are all up online on
OpenCourseWare for free there's no
signup required you can pick and choose
what you want to learn and you can do it
at your own pace
you